I think that this was handled very badly by Chad. I actually
Do you know what? I think that the Tommy C stuff was handled
really badly by Chad. Um Back it now! No! No! The issue is that
Tommy was correct and all these people are talking [__]
behind the scenes and Nicholas was so sort of keeping the bridge
open, but not really, right? He wasn't actually keeping the bridge
open. No! No! No! No!
So, I said that basically Chad uh the story came out between
like 6:00 and 10:00 p.m. the night before and then by 8:00 in
the morning Chad had already announced that like the great sweep
has begun. People like Bowblax and Tipster get spoken about for
year for like a year and then it's nothing to see here for this
and it's nothing to see here for this. Now, I've not looked at
this yet, but I've got a feeling
that the sweepers are going to be in on this one, okay? And by
watching this, it is increasingly obvious this is like a direct
shot at me. At best, you can call it a direct shot at me and
Augie. And then the next day, he adapts this take to be about
everybody else and he's like, "Wait, I'm listening. I'm talking
about sensitive society, mate. You're just being sensitive."
Just listen, it's obviously a shot at me. This is obviously a
knife to the back immediately after my friend got accused of
being like a racist I think that was really the start of the
end. That was the point at which people were like, "Yeah, this
Chad guy can't really be trusted." I got an angry DM from Nicholas.
Nicholas was in my phone here once again. So, if you guys forget,
basically Nicholas Ybarra went hard on Chad over his lack of
Turkey Tom response when Chad went on vacation. Chad had been
saying he was going on vacation. I think he started talking about
it like a month before he left, 2 months before he left, maybe.
People knew Chad was going to Vietnam like months before he left
for Vietnam and then he explicitly said, "Hey, if I'm on vacation,
there's been a rule he's stuck to in the past where he's like,
'On vacation, I don't respond to internet [__] I'm
just on vacation.'" So, Tom posted a response after Chad left,
and Chud didn't react to it, and Nicholas like went kind of hard
on him and started talking about just started talking all kinds
of [__] Okay, so Chud's back from vacation now. He's
very angry at Nicholas DeOrio. He's not happy with this guy.
Now, I think at this point I have to go and cover the Beckett
stuff cuz I I might be able to talk to Beckett after. Now, I
hope I see people saying Beckett was sweeping here, okay? I see
that allegation being made, but I don't know how substantial
that allegation is. I don't know how real that allegation is,
okay? Is that allegation real?
Or is that like people really hate
I I need somebody I need somebody other
one person who's saying this, okay? I got to see more. Beckett's
like a nice person. Beckett is
uh how do I put this?
I think when Beckett something up, it's probably if he if he
were to [__] something up, it's probably because
he is um
like making good making assumptions positively about other people.
That's that's that would be my thing. It would never be like
him maliciously trying to [__] somebody over. I don't
think. That's my opinion, okay? I listen to people I like and
respect. So, yeah. And I mean, that's that's an accusation that's
been thrown at me about Queenman.
Um that I listen I listen to Queenman before too much. Uh I don't
know how true that is. But, the reality is this. Um
I think that this was handled very badly by Chud. I actually
Do you know what? I think that uh the TommyC stuff was handled
really badly by Chud. UM I THINK BECKETT, NO! NO! NO!
NO! NO! NO! NO!
NO! NO! NO! NO! NO! Come on, man.
Come on, man.
think Tommy was uh forgetting this head up about it and going
on on crusade. I've said this to Tommy, and I've said this to
Chud. But, I think responding to the Tommy stuff was like the
dumbest thing Chud could do. Because Tommy's accusation against
Chud was Chud will
make you into content.
Like, it doesn't matter about your
That accusation is
Every single commentary streamer makes every single other commentary
issue into content. That's the entire point of this
People getting a little fight, that becomes content for everybody.
What are we doing?
>> your previous relationships, he is waiting to cannibalize
you. And then Chud, by responding to it, just proves Tommy's
point. And the target for Tommy's Wait, when does Beckett see
people like getting fights and he doesn't cover it? Is that something
he does? Is Beckett just saying like, "Actually, if my friend
gets in a fight with somebody and they lose, I like don't cover
it. If my friend is saying something bad about my other friend,
I just don't cover it."
Is that Sushi's good. Is that Is that what he's saying? I don't
even know what he's saying here. The issue with the Tommy stuff
is that he was saying a bunch of things. He was speaking for
Nicholas DeOrio. Nicholas DeOrio never came out and said Tommy
is like wrong.
I'm actually friends with Chud. He never said that. I What's
confusing >> point wasn't the audience, it was other
That's what Tommy was going for.
It's like, don't respond to it. Why res- Why respond to this?
Why respond to the crazy old man yelling at clouds? It just seemed
like a really stupid decision. Because he objectively wasn't
yelling at clouds and everything he said was correct. And that's
what makes it up that DeOrio or any of those people didn't come
out and say it was wrong or or else
then all of those people are like not saying anything publicly,
but all hate Chud behind the scenes. The issue is that Tommy
was correct, and all these people are talking [__]
behind the scenes, and Nicholas was so sort of keeping the bridge
open, but not really. Right? He wasn't actually keeping the bridge
open.
That's the problem. Yeah, that's my that's my opinion around
that. I think that was the I think that was a really major misstep.
Um
you know Tommy is a paranoid
Wait, why why is that not a misstep by
Not coming up and clearing that up. If D'Orio still wants a bridge
with Chud, if he's actually keeping lines of communication open,
he's trying to remain friends with Chud in any way
why is he not cleaning that up? Can can I I don't understand
where's back maybe back at Old Man in the >> can't respond
to him seriously. True.
But yeah, it's just like all Tommy then. What did Tommy make
up? What Tommy was telling everybody that Chud was a snake.
That's what he was doing. That everybody hated Chud and Chud
was a total snake.
And you're going to find out that this guy's like evil. And everybody
hates him. All these people hate him.
And then none of the people he's speaking for who he has open
who who all openly like him have relationships. Willy Mac gets
on his stream with him. None of those people correct. Uh look
up his quote at the time. He said something that it made it clear
he agreed with Tommy C. Uh Nick or someone else. And had to do
was go like when people asked him about it, he go, "Well, look
at Chud's reaction to me. Look at Chud's reaction to me. If these
snake comments aren't true, why is Chud flying off the handle
and saying that I'm a drunk who has to like lean on his wife?"
And that's exactly what he did. So, he
I wait, are credibility attacks good or
Are credibility attacks good or bad?
Cuz I if I just watched that Nicholas D'Orio stream correctly,
attacks on credibility are apparently the highest the most paramount
the the scariest and most necessary to deal with attacks that
Was that not what Nick was just saying? Is that not an attack
on Chud's
And you're saying that the correct move for move for Chud when
And guy attacks his credibility is to do nothing. To say nothing.
I I don't get it.
What are you normalizing here? Uh actually, just don't respond
to somebody talking [__] about you. Don't respond.
Don't say anything. Don't do anything. Just let it go. Just let
it go. Just let it go. It's fine. It's fine. Why would you want
to respond to it?
YOU'RE JUST YOU'RE JUST [laughter] HANDING HIM THE AMMUNITION.
Why would you do that?
I just I Yeah, I don't I don't get why you'd make that decision.
I'd say it's it's an odd one. Um Slug with the two uh I think
What Diesel likes Ferrari? So, I don't know.
Okay, that takes but it's not like they're the take on Diorio,
I guess. The Dior streamer or anything. What about that? Jesus
Christ. Uh okay.
But was it true? Was it true? That's an interesting question.
The reality Well, I mean, from the perspective of Will Chud Logic
turning you into content,
No, all of the other things Tommy said.
The question is how much you care about that. And some people
are going to be like, "Well, it's What do you care?"
Don't Why would you give a [__] if people turn you
into content? None of this really matters. I don't know. It's
a difficult one. I think that I think that proximity matters.
I think that if you are close with somebody and then they'll
turn you into [__]
then you're kind of Yeah, people are going to get [__]
off with you.
Why Where is the requirement?
Are we Are we ignoring the fact that Tommy C turned their relationship
into content first?
So, Chud Logic should say, "Okay, Tommy C's turning my relationship
into content saying, 'I'm actually a snake because I turn people's
relationships into because I, Chud Logic, turn people's relationships
into content. So, I can't respond, otherwise I'm a snake.'"
What? This This can only work with somebody as and useless as
Tommy C, by the way, because that's the argument he's actually
making. Tommy C's like a totally wretched individual, so by responding
to him, you're basically like normalizing him and you're you're
you're I I don't even know. Like, he's so wretched that responding
to him is actually like negative to you.
I don't
This is obviously not a standard you hold for anything.
This doesn't make any sense.
I guess the the issue here is that Tommy's words have weight,
right? The issue is not that like if Tommy was a ranting lunatic
who had no relationship, if it was like um Uh who's a good example?
Uh I'm trying to think of a good example. Let Let's say it's
just a random chatter who doesn't talk to Nick, has never talked
to Nick, has never talked to Turkey Tom, never talked to Willy
Mac. And this chatter is saying it, you can ignore them. Even
a content creator who has no relationship, you can ignore them.
Tommy has a direct line to these people. Tommy is speaking with
their voice, provably so, right?
That's the problem. That's the obvious issue here. It's Tommy
is speaking directly with their voice. That's what we're upset
about. That's what Chud would be upset about. That's what everybody
was upset about. It's like me personally, I was like, "Dude,
why wouldn't you come out If you're friends with this guy, why
wouldn't you say something here?" It doesn't make any sense to
me. Bro, what is Beckett on? The main TommyC thing was Chud was
a snake, not Chud will make content on I think technically Chud
will make content on you, that's the way he's a snake. But yes,
it was that Chud's a snake and everybody knows he's a snake,
everybody hates him behind the scenes.
It's It's basically attacking Chud's credibility, saying he like
lies about you. He's going to like try to try to you over any
chance he gets.
He wasn't trying to [__] Tommy over. He was responding
to Tommy.
So, it's just it's totally disingenuous.
The The TommyC stuff we could argue about a lot, me and Beckett.
Okay, I'll write that down. I don't think that's crazy. I think
we're all like that. But if it's somebody you're not that close
with, why would you like why give a [__] right?
That seems that seems pretty obvious. Like I I just Yeah, right?
If you've got if you're close with somebody and they start like
talking [__] about you, like let's say you're just
at like university. There's no way There's no way. There's no
way. And you're like friends with somebody. Something happens
at a party that's a bit embarrassing and you find like one of
your best mates chatting about it in the common room the next
day. You're going to be a bit off with them in comparison to
just some random person. You're like, "What the fuck?"
But if your best mate talked to his friend and you see that friend
who you know got the news from your from your best mate talking
about it, you're not going to be upset? You just let that go?
Like we we agree we introduce one degree of indirection and suddenly
you don't get to respond. You should just let it go. Are you
out of your [__] mind?
What the [__] are we talking about here? That's crazy,
right? Like because that's what happened is basically
it's this exact thing happened, but instead of the best friend
talking about it, it's like his friend who you're not really
that close to, but he's really close to and you know that they
talked about it cuz that guy's saying, "Hey, your best friend
told me about this about you." And then you're and then you see
your best friend sitting across the room and he sort of just
like avoids your eyes, avoids eye contact and like looks off
into the
And it's like, "Dude, are you going to Did you tell him about
this?" And he just does nothing. We're not going to get a like,
"Hey, I didn't mean to do that." We're not going to get anything.
That's just how it goes. Okay. I got I guess so. Right. Get your
TommyC tin foil hats for tomorrow's stream. Tommy's going to
have a field day. Tommy just needs to stop working with Keemstar.
I mean, really, what's the dude? He's doing so well. Who cares?
Um I mean, this is why I stopped being friends with Given Ant
because I realized he was a [__] person. Yeah, I
mean, it's it's one of those like from a commenter perspective,
that's almost what you want, I would argue. But at the same time
like if you're trying to maintain relationships, you do have
this massive com-
Are you pretending Beckett isn't a lower version of Dickers?
Uh I don't really think there's anything wrong with Dickers,
despite what you guys say.
Uh like there's no major flaw in his content, no major flaw that
I see. He seems to just like put work into it. Okay, but
Beckett gets Beckett's was almost at 500 viewers just a second
ago. What are you talking about? Beckett gets a lot of viewers.
Beckett's huge.
conflict. I think the question is as well, like shots across
the bow, right? Like how much do you care about those
those little um needling and pinpointing attacks? Does it matter?
And that's going to come down to the
Like I I've maintained relationships who've got with people who've
got loads of little needling [__]
jabs against me. But then I don't really care about them. So,
I've just
Okay, that's totally fine. But what if you suspected that like
like I think I'm friends with Beckett, okay?
I think I'm friends with Beckett. What if I was What if, you
know,
BB Poison? Or what if Rile came out? Or Yeah, let's let's use
Rile. What if Rile came out and said, "Actually, Beckett's a
total [__] and J Stalk thinks so, too." And then
I'm like sitting here, I'm on Twitter, people are like adding
me on Twitter asking like what the [__] is this about?
And I never respond. I just let it go. Yeah, J Stalk hates this
guy. Yeah, J Stalk thinks this guy's a total piece of [__]
Do I think Do I think Beckett doesn't get a chance to respond
or doesn't get What if it's even worse? What if it's like an
attack on your credibility? J Stalk says that Beckett's like
a total liar, a totally disingenuous loser who actually shouldn't
be taken seriously. He lies so much, he shouldn't be taken seriously.
And Rile says that, and I never ever say anything.
I just don't do anything about it. That's crazy, isn't it? I'm
not sure I'm all the way through it. >> It I just it doesn't
make a difference to My opinion is that other people's audiences
don't really matter that much. And the overall impact is actually
incredibly low. So, who gives a [__] right? I talk
about cartoon pony drama. Like, who gives who cares, bro? Um
but that is not the case for everybody. That is not the case
for everybody. Okay.
So, are we sort of like is that is that enough of a preamble?
I mostly this is mostly a preamble of I called this [__]
happening. I deserve some flowers.
>> That's where we are. Cuz we're going to do we're going
to do I haven't covered Yeah, Beckett Beckett streams to art
commentary people. They're they're like literally writing on
a tablet. They're drawing [__] on a tablet right
now.
Sorry. I'm supposed to call Beckett. Uh how you doing? How you
doing, Justin?
Uh doing pretty well. So, let's talk a little bit about some
of the [__] right? Have you watched Nick's full stream?
No.
Yeah, I've watched basically all of it. I mean, don't have the
last 5 minutes or something. So, we'll start with this Tommy
Yeah, let's start with the Tommy
For sure. Let's start with the Tommy thing. So, so Um Give me
a criticism. Give me a criticism. Let's start there. >> Oh,
so you didn't say what the main motivation was of Tommy like
or sorry, the main criticism, which is I Do we think Do we think
credibility attacks are important? Yeah. Yeah, credibility attacks
are important. Okay. So, Tommy is Do you think there's a tangible
difference? Okay, the the metaphor you used was like if you come
down and you see like your mate talking [__] about
you after some some stuff goes down, you'd be upset about it.
But if it's somebody you don't really know or don't care about,
it's not that big a deal,
Okay, so now what if it's like somebody who's a friend of your
friend
who you don't really get along with or don't really know that
well, but they're saying, "Hey, your best mate, your the guy
you like trust is actually he hates you. He's talking [__]
about you. He says you're a snake. He says you have no credibility.
Uh well, okay. What do you mean? Like just just lay this out
a bit more simple rather than just garden pathing me. Give me
a take.
Oh, the take is that
Tommy's saying, uh this guy's a snake cuz he makes content out
of people while making content out of Chud. There's no like downside.
It's like the whole the whole thing about being a snake would
be making content out of people who you're not willing to do
content with or you don't want to make content out of Tommy is
opening himself up for that. There's no snake criticism. Anybody
who's willing to say Tommy won or or it was stupid for Chud to
respond is just
like horribly. Uh okay. So,
it doesn't matter what Tommy said. It matters what Tommy's intention
was. So, Tommy's intention with this was to basically go after
Chud's credibility not in the eyes of the audience but in the
eyes of other content creators.
the play is hey, ChudLogic will make content out of anybody and
when he does regardless of previous relationships will be bad
faith about it because he doesn't care about you. He doesn't
like your relationship with him is just dependent on like how
useful you are to him either as a connection or as content. Because
Tommy is tiny and but also well connected with other content
creators. Chud responding is the wrong thing to do because ignoring
it's just the obviously better option because like all Tommy
has to do is go look, see Chud's responding to me. It doesn't
matter what Tommy says. All Tommy's play needs to be is look
at Chud's response. Yeah, I'm not talking about the content You
understand? Anybody who thinks that that response like makes
Chud Chud look like a snake or proves Tommy correct is being
a right? Like a slobbering
Yeah, but it begins with the >> think it makes Tommy correct.
You're arguing that that's you're you're not arguing that he's
correct. You're arguing that that was his goal and it could be
successful. But I don't think it could be successful to anybody
who's not obviously motivated against Chud. Well, it seems so,
but it but it seems to be because it seems to have had that effect
with other commentators, right? Because Tommy's the one who's
waving that flag. >> mean? Along with other people like
>> do you think Tommy was lying? Because the whole point
of that content was actually all of your friends think you're
a snake, all of your friends hate you. Which content creators
did Tommy
Cuz all of the ones that were actually close to Chud were already
convinced. So which which content creators did Tommy convince?
Who were they? Cuz I don't think I don't think Nick was in any
way
I don't think Nick was at all convinced.
>> Tommy was saying that he was convinced.
I think Tommy is wrong on that cuz otherwise Nick would have
gone after Chud ages ago and burnt the bridge with >> If
Tommy was wrong on that >> when this was happening and
even when this was happening
>> Because Nick was like, I'm not getting involved with
talking about any of this stuff. He did the same thing with uh
with the Willy stuff when Willy came out with a video about Augie.
>> Yeah, that's the standard of a totally disingenuous
loser. Like obviously he is he likes what's happening in both
of those situations, obviously, right? Or he would step in.
Wait, why would he like what happened what's happening in both
those situations? Why would he like >> upset with both
of those people. He's upset he's upset with Queenan
and me. So he is perfectly happy to let us be painted as doxers
and to amplify that and never disavow it. And he is upset with
Chud. So he's totally willing to let that be amplified by somebody
else even though they're invoking him. But I'm not talking about
talking about
But I'm not talking about with you and Queenan and Chud. I'm
talking about with very specifically I said that with Augie and
Willy, right? Two people that Nick is friends with. He was like,
I'm not getting involved. Wait, what?
So with the Willy stuff when when Nick said that he wasn't going
to get involved
it was the Augie and Willy stuff that cuz Willy brought out a
video saying that Augie was involved in this and said he He Yeah,
and then Nick was like, "Well, I'm not getting involved in this."
And he also said in that stream, "I told Willy not that it was
a bad idea to release that video, right?"
Where did
Yeah, that is a total cop-out on any serious criticism.
Um doesn't live Sure, but it again in his community is actually
hold up.
Like you think you think Nicholas was
He actually looks like the most disin- like nothing hurts his
credibility more than amplifying the totally defamatory, totally
lying Willy video and then never disavowing it, right? Like obviously
that hurts Nick's credibility massively. Okay, with who though?
With anybody who's paying attention. With anybody intelligent
who's paying >> because because this is only ultimately
I think that the like the stuff that Willy has put out around
the doxing [__] absolutely hurts people's credibility
for not addressing it. And I think that it's like again putting
out accusations where you don't have the full amount of informa-
or you're not presenting the full information to the public or
like to to people generally is going to hurt your credibility.
I've said this about like the Willy stuff where Queen Man was
like, "Willy is uh was getting fed information by Erodite for
his video." And I was like, "Well, you've got no evidence for
that. Show me the [__] evidence." And he didn't and
we had to wait for Kilo to come out months later for it. Yes,
obviously you should show evidence for those claims. Willy doesn't
seem to have that [__] evidence. And that's >> Sure. So,
I still think the uh the lack of disavowal, so after retweeting
Willy's video that is totally defamatory, the lack of disavowal
and and separating himself from the lies was huge huge hit to
his credibility,
I don't I don't know how you could disagree there. To for you
if you retweeted a video that was accusing somebody of so like
of doxing
would you not want to go and correct like the misinformation
in that video? Would you not feel compelled to? That feels like
a pretty obvious ethical obligation, no? >> I think part
of the problem Okay,
that feels like a pretty obvious ethical obligation, no?
Well, yeah, but at the same time
like the position everyone seems to have right now is that the
Willy stuff like they're just trusting Willy. Now, I've got my
own problems around this [__] which I'm not denying.
But, it's like
yeah, Nick seems to have just distanced entirely from talking
about any of this [__] around you guys, right?
Like I'm not saying I'm not saying I'm not like >> the
video. He retweeted the video. Why are you coping right now?
Please. Please. He retweeted the video. He wasn't opting out.
He was amplifying the video, right? >> That's sure.
Sure. And so, if you retweeted a video that was accusing somebody
of doxing and then you found out that that was a total lie, you
would feel compelled that would be an ethical obligation on your
part to disavow that and make correct to your audience that information,
right?
Okay, I need to see his coverage of this too I cuz I haven't
to kind of give a take around this. Because I don't know what
Nick said. And at the same time, if Nick's position is I just
trust Willy's got the evidence and has done the research and
believes these guys are involved in his doxing or whatever was
supposed to be said. Um like I don't know. The only thing I have
seen Nick say about this video publicly, again, the only thing
I've seen him say about it is I don't think that Willy should
have made it. And I told him that he shouldn't release it. And
I think the accusations against Augie uh within it are a little
bit crazy. That's all I've seen Nick say about it.
That's bad, right? Because he amplified it? Because he retweeted
the video?
I don't know like Okay, hold on. What are we talking about amplified
head? It seems like a rabbit hole. He's talking about somebody
who's like friendly with Willy. He like tweets out Willy's video
on Destiny. And again, but says also says publicly that that
like generally I don't think this is a good route to to go down
with the personal attacks and you should have the evidence for
it.
Right? What? Is that not a disavow? I mean, he's not referencing
you
in particular,
but like the only take I've seen him give about this publicly
is I told Willie he shouldn't bring the video out. It's a bad
idea to go down this route. And if you're going to make accusations,
you need the [__] evidence for it.
Is that not a kind of a disavow and going, well, it doesn't hold
up. >> No, it's not it's it's not a disavow on the same
platform he amplified it on unless he tweeted it. Did he tweet
it?
This was said public said on his stream. I don't know. I don't
like the cross thing. Like people who are getting his tweets,
the vast majority are going to see his streams, right?
Like I I don't know. Um, like I don't view it that way. No, I
don't I I don't I don't I don't view Twitter that way. Or like
if you say something on like one platform, you you've done the
disavow. You don't need to like cross platform. Evaluate the
statement, sorry. Evaluate the statement you just made. Way more
people see his streams than his tweets. Like we know that's obviously
not true. The people who are engaging with him, who are listening
to his takes, are watching his streams. It's not going to be
a load of people on Twitter being like, well, Nicholas DeOrio
tweeted this out. So therefore, it's a full of that like, dude,
now I need to go and watch it. Anybody who's thinking that or
is that level with Nick is going to be watching his streams,
surely. I disagree, but we don't need to continue cuz there's
going to be hard for us to prove that. I disagree, but it being
like a 30-second statement in a stream instead of being crystallized
in the same way the tweet was, I think that does a lot. He boosted
in the algorithm, boosted these lies in the algorithm. I guess
that's obviously true. >> round to we're reeling round
to credibility stuff on
DeOrio from months ago, which we have talked about before. And
again, I have publicly said, cuz like I'm not a million miles
away from you on this position, right? Cuz I've publicly said
the stuff that like within that video and making doxing allegations
without any [__] hard evidence presented or still
presented is
right? I've I I'm not a million miles away from from this. Um
from you on But like I'm trying to like I guess like
where we're at now with this Chud stuff
feels different unless your like point is Nicholas burnt Chud
because of Willy. Which I don't think is the case. >> sorry,
my whole point is that Nicholas when he doesn't engage with things,
when things are happening that would be against his principles
his stated principles and he doesn't engage it's because he likes
the thing that's happening. He thinks the person deserves it.
Right?
So when Tommy is saying all these things about Chud it maybe
not even against his principles. But when when Tommy is saying
this stuff about Chud and and Tommy is literally saying like
yeah Nick thinks this everybody thinks this about you. Nick doesn't
come out and disavow it because he likes that that's happening.
He's not unaware of it. He just likes what's happening.
Just like when he didn't disavow the Willy video, he likes the
outcome from the Willy video.
So you think that Nick was sat there going oh thank god Willy
Tommy's gone after Chud because I don't want to.
Wait, you understand that if he didn't believe that stuff, if
he didn't think that he could have just said actually I didn't
say that. But I'm not going to get more involved. I'll just correct
lies but I'm not going to That's obviously what you are like
bound to do in any friendship, right? You've two friends who
are fighting with each other. One of them invokes your friendship
and something you've said to them to attack the other person.
If you haven't said that, you correct them, right?
Even if you have said that you might say well don't pull me into
this.
I don't Do you know what? I don't even think Nick even watched
it.
Yeah, did Nick even comment on this Tommy Chud fallout?
I don't know if he commented on it. His point is he didn't disavow
it. >> I mean I'm trying to like no. Because Tommy is using
his word to impugn Chud's credibility.
So this goes back to the the example >> to see if there's
any like evidence of Nick ever seeing this or caring.
Why does it matter? Like why does why does I hold on. Why does
it matter? Like how close do you think Nick and Tommy are these
days?
Because Nick's not like jumping on the >> If they're not
close, this doesn't get better for you, right? If they're not
close and he says he's trying to keep a line open with Chud
then why wouldn't he correct to correct it, right? He did see
it. The further away they get, the more impetus he has to correct
it, right?
So so okay, so what's the argument here that Chud I'm just again
I'm just trying to follow the line so >> is that Nicholas
likes Chud's credibility being attacked and he was totally fine
with his word being used to attack Chud's credibility. He never
corrected it.
I think I think Nick my impression is that he's sick of like
people around him fighting and him getting dragged into it, which
is exactly what Nick said. So Nick not wanting to get involved
is exactly in line with what Nick has said that he wants. He
just like don't involve me in this.
I understand that he's saying don't involve me I don't think
I don't think he was But you understand you're involved when
somebody lies about the things you say or they invoke you to
attack somebody else's credibility. You've now been involved.
So you take if it's a lie, you correct it or if it's something
you stand on, you just say yeah, like that happened, maybe it's
a little different but don't involve me anymore.
Letting it happen implicitly says you agree with it and you're
good with it. So wait, hold on. Um Apparently Adam believes that
him and Nick talked about the Tommy and Chud stuff at VidCon.
So Nick was aware of it.
Okay. Well again kind of who can I see okay, here's part of my
thing with this. Like I just I the accusation is >> but
you you when I when you say I don't even know this or that and
then I give you some piece of information that proves this or
that and you say I don't even know if I care. That is rough for
me. Okay? Sorry, I don't want to be a debate panelist, but you
understand, right? >> Sure. The The issue I have is I'm
not sure what Nick is supposed to do because like okay, so Nick's
options here are essentially come out publicly
and like let's say Nick is annoyed over like the Chud's Willy
coverage or whatever. So the option would be either Nick comes
out publicly and burns his relationship with Chud or Nick comes
out publicly to defend Tommy. Now let's say you're right and
Nick was like yeah, sure. I disagree with Chud's coverage. And
like whatever it's really annoyed me. It's caused problems. I
don't know why Chud's going down this route. Um like his only
option then is to go and burn Chud publicly, right? Or burn Tommy
publicly. Those are the two choice you're given. Or he can just
go I'm just I'm just not I'm just staying out of it. I want to
maintain my friendship with Chud even if I disagree with him.
Tommy's the person who's taken his word and put it in public.
You You burn the person who tries to invoke you, right? Well,
not if not if you like let's say you agree with them in some
way or you just want to get involved or you're just like listen,
this is small like drama and I don't want to get involved in
So obviously No. No, it's no small You said it right the first
time. Yes, you like you agree with it, you like it, you're fine
with it. And that's my reasoning for why Chud is totally justified
to respond because if Nick didn't agree with it, he would have
said something. Because he agrees with it, it is a credibility
attack that's not going to be taken by Nick's word. >> you're
missing the point. It's not about justified in responding, it's
about it's dumb to respond. It's not about justification. There
are plenty of things that people are justified in doing that
it's still a dumb thing to do. Like my point isn't Chud was wrong
to respond on some ethical level. >> Tommy is speaking
with Nick's voice there. And he's speaking with that voice to
content creators. As you said, that's his goal. He is saying
to a bunch of content creators, Nick doesn't like this guy anymore.
Do you think Chud shouldn't respond to this? Yes, I think Chud
shouldn't have responded to it. Why? It's incredibly It's a direct
credibility attack that's being lent weight by Nick's reputation.
Why should he not respond to that?
because the point is
that like the underlying point is you like and Tommy does this
in one of the streams. He's like, well, wait, if it's not true,
why are you spending so much time spiraling over it? It's like
That was a stream watched by barely anybody
that and Tommy has like at the time like a hundred concurrents.
Like this is like Tommy is long past it. So, Chud giving it the
time of day on a far larger platform
is just signal boosting it. I'm not talking about the ethics
of whether you respond. I'm saying like if Chud hadn't responded,
it wouldn't have led to anything. It would just die in the pan.
And many of the like the the relationships that were burnt at
the time for him, like Tom, like Willie, You know it's not going
to die in the pan. You know it's not You know it's not going
to die in the pan. Why not?
There's a sickly
kid in my chat right now who wouldn't let it die almost certainly.
But beyond that or
But like hold on. But I'm talking about Chud responding. I'm
not talking about Queenman responding to it. I'm talking about
Chud responding to it because the minute like Chud responded
to it like >> Yes, but it's not about Queenman. Well, it's
partly about Queenman, but it's not like a direct attack on Queenman
in the same way >> It's a lot about Queenman, isn't it?
It's a lot about Queenman, sure. But like again, it's not an
attack on Queenman in the same way it's an attack on Chud. I'm
just talking about the strategy of it here. Chud gained nothing
by responding to it because he was responding in to it in a way
that was a response to the audience
of what Tommy was saying. But the like and I mean the chat here.
But what Tommy was cultivating
was here is what I'm saying about Chud Logic. Look at the way
Chud Logic handles stuff. Look at what he's saying about like
my wife. Look at what he's saying about me being an alcoholic.
Look at these personal ties. This is a guy I thought we were
cool with. That was the angle Tommy was taking. By responding
to it, you're just signal boosting it rather than just letting
it die in the pan. I'm just saying saying the strategy of like
you just ignore that [__] And we all do this, by
the way. There were all things that like people will say about
you and you just go ah I just don't need to respond to that.
It's irrelevant. It doesn't have any impact on the world.
>> where somebody who's very close to a massive creator
that you're close to is saying that massive creator thinks you
have no credibility. Thinks you're a lying snake.
And then you don't respond or somebody doesn't respond. You can't
find that example. If it's somebody with no credibility as in
they can't speak with that person's voice, it's just a schizophrenic,
then maybe you have an argument, but Tommy does speak to Nick.
Tommy was speaking to Nick all the time. Willie was in Willie
was in Tommy's chat for some of these streams. Sure.
But again, like it like what's the uh from my own experience
here and from yours, there have been plenty of times where we
have responded where we probably shouldn't have done. I shouldn't
have responded to a lot of the Willie stuff at the time.
It didn't do me any favors. It just like burned a relationship.
>> Apparently Nick was in chat for some of those streams,
too, in Tommy's chat. Okay, sure.
But it's like okay, sure. So I don't know what So what's the
line here? So should Nick have just burned Chud months
I rather than like running around behind the scenes talking [__]
yeah, probably.
Well, was he running around behind the scenes talking [__]
Because I again, I'm close to Tommy and I haven't seen
How did Tommy find out about any of
Would you Well, I again, it could be a conversation. It could
be something like taken out of context. Could be through Willie.
Could be through anyone. Like it could be that to Nick said something
offhand about being annoyed at some of Willie's coverage. It
could be Tommy running with something. But again, as soon as
Tommy crystallizes it, he puts it into words, and then Nick is
around. Nick is seeing it. Nick knows it's happening. Then, Nick
agrees with it if he's not going to correct anything, right?
Okay, maybe maybe Nick did agree with it. I don't I don't really
understand what the argument here is. If Nick's out here reaching
out to Chud and trying to resolve things privately, if you and
I had an issue, and I said something in like private chat about
you, and I was like, "Oh, [__] me, Just Up did this
But, I'm not saying anything publicly, and I'm still talking
to you, and I'm like, "Hey, man, I have an issue with like what
you're saying." Which is what Nick did, by the way. Like, he's
reaching out to Chud in DMs.
If Nick's doing all that, like, I don't I don't get what Like,
so
Nick had an issue, so he should have instantly burned the bridge.
It It could just be that Nick was like, "I Chud's
wrong on this thing with Willy, and I want to defend Willy, or
like I I agree with Willy." But, that's I don't know. The argument
seems to be like Nick's meant to like escalate horrifically,
and like burn his entire relationship with Chud to the ground
over this. I just think that's a little bit extreme. They were
They weren't just like making content around each other. These
two were friends. >> Probably, if you think there's a friendship
there, in my opinion, you say, "Well, that's not true. I don't
think Chud's like a snake who can't be trusted." And then, you
reach out again and try to talk to him.
You could You could easily We could think of a way you could
easily do this with Tommy with that doesn't burn either of them.
Tommy, I was venting about something that's kind of related Tommy
is sort of spreading a little bit >> I disagree. I dis-
No, I disagree. The minute anyone says >> you disagree
with? publicly in the space of I said something about Tommy the
other day, and multiple people ran to Tommy's chat to be like,
"Beckett's talking [__] about you." Like, it's Like,
there is an actual situation now where no one really can say
anything publicly, because Let's say Nick had done that, and
be like, "Yeah, I don't think Chud Logic's a snake." Then, all
that would have happened would a million people would have run
And obviously, that's That's an exaggeration. Would have run
to Tommy trying to further stir the pot and exact uh like like
make this more than it was. This is part of the problem with
the response at all. It's not just like happening in a vacuum
or in isolation between a couple of content creators. It's happening
with a couple couple of content creators with people on both
sides who want to see this fight happen. Um and like who just
want to see the fire start.
I mean, I might be one of those people. I'm not disagreeing with
that. Well, yeah, sure. So So again, like if Nick said something
publicly, let's say that happened. Like there was like "Ah, ChudLogic's
not a not a snake. Don't know what you're talking about." You'd
go live and then be like, "This is a clip from Nick disavowing
Tommy, right?"
I I'm saying that there's an easy way you can make that statement.
It's like, "I understand why I was venting." There's an easy
way that Tommy could have misunderstood this. I think he misunderstood
slightly. Uh I was mad at Chud over like some comment he made.
It's not that big a deal.
People could farm that, but I mean, people farm [__]
all the time. I don't I don't think that burns you though. Sure.
But I just Okay. Sure. I just don't see like Again, I think this
would have escalated
far more publicly if Nick had said anything at the time. It seems
that from Nick's DMs he was he was he was he was he was he was
he was he was >> it wasn't happening and both of these
avoiding any conflict for months and we haven't gotten to a public
place. Well, we seem to be the public place now,
Yeah, well, that's what I'm saying is is keeping this private
didn't really seem to solve anything. Sort of just kept it blowing
like boiling below the surface. >> that I mean, my my argument
would be again like my argument would be like this should have
been solved privately because it's a friendship drama. Or they
should have jumped on a stream with a moderate with a neutral
moderator and had a controlled conversation.
Right? Yeah. I don't know why I don't I don't like this argument
of like Nick needed to get on Chud's stream. I think
Because we all know how this I do not think Chud is arguing that.
I think you're totally disingenuous if you think Chud was like
you have to call him out. >> think I don't think I don't
think I don't think Chud's arguing that, but I think other people
are people in my chat have said this. I think this I think there
are people who are like, "Why won't Nick just get on a Chud stream?"
If they say Chud stream, I'm almost positive they just mean get
on any stream and talk publicly. Which by the >> Sure, and
they should have Well, I don't I don't think they should have
had a public conversation about this at all. It's clearly a It's
clearly a behind-the-scenes friendship drama and they should
have just like talked about it privately. And I And again, I've
said this multiple times tonight, they should have been done
months ago and they should have resolved the issue and they didn't
and then here we are. Yeah, sure. I think I would also criticize
Chud for dropping the ball there on on reaching out. Like he
said, "We could do the call." And then Nick says, "Okay." And
then day later Nick says like, "Okay, we can do the call this
week." And then Chud doesn't hit him back. I don't know what's
going on there. I think that's on Chud. But it's like one of
those things where it's it's still on both people to like talk
at some point.
still be reaching out to Chud, right?
I think it's Yeah, but I think it's like it's kind of [__]
up that Chud is Do you disagree? Like have you How much of Nick's
thing have you watched with the leaked DMs? I watched the whole
thing before stream, so.
I don't know if you know if I was getting DM'd by people and
[__] but like if I've missed something you can fill
me in, but go on. Do you Do you disagree that like the thing
that's happening that Chud's describing, his problem is that
he has he has two problems. He doesn't just have one problem.
He's got two problems. He's got Um one problem is I think people
in my chat want us to fight. The other problem is I genu He He
genuinely thinks Ethan Sorry, Nick is sweeping for Ethan. And
by not saying anything, he is in fact sweeping for Nick. Right?
And these two problems actually can't both be resolved. They
They literally like work against each other. Any resolution that
you go towards with one actually [__] with the other.
So, if he says anything about Nick's coverage of Ethan, that's
going to make their relationship worse. It's going to give people
more ammo to for the fight. And if he tries to just not say anything,
gives people way more ammo to say, "Hey, you won't even call
out your friend who's sucking this guy's
Right? And he will actually be doing that. That's that's the
other thing Nick doesn't seem to understand is that Chud is not
worried about people saying he's a sweeper. People say he's a
sweeper over everything, right? Chud didn't call Turkey Tom like
a diaper matching
immediately, and people would have called him a sweeper for that,
right?
It's about sure. He would be actually sweeping in this case.
That's the problem is he's actually sweeping. He's actually like
not calling out something that he thinks is wrong.
And Nick never helps him resolve that. Nick Nick never helps
him resolve that at all. There's like one case where he's like,
"Oh, here are like some things people sometimes accuse me." I
don't even know if the DMs are cut off there. He's like, "I think
I I can't remember. He lists like some general problems he's
probably seen people hit him on Twitter for. Not even like the
biggest issues with some of his coverage. But he again, he wants
to talk about that in private. He wants to talk about the problems
with his coverage in private while Chud has to stay silent in
public. Chud has to not call Nick out for for the problems he
has in public. You understand that's putting Chud in a bad position,
right?
But Chud's not covering the Ethan and Hasan Destiny stuff and
wanted to stay and seems to have wanted to stay away from that
drama.
May- Maybe I'm reading into it. >> you think that he thinks
that he would be putting himself in a bad position
>> What? Because he thinks it did lead to conflict between
like him and Nick. Okay, well then isn't that a situation which
he's created rather than going cuz again, like Destiny has said
before like I don't know. I can't speak for him. But hold on.
But I know other people who have disagreed with Nick on the Ethan
and Hasan Destiny stuff. Myself included. I literally sat here
and said that anybody was who was like sweeping or protecting
or like supporting this lawsuit was out their [__]
mind. I didn't have any issues. I said it very
I said it very publicly multiple times with in commentary Did
you call him the chief Did you call it the sweeper in chief directly
by name?
I said that I said that Nick seems to have moved on his ecosystem
points and I don't think that's I I'm like fair enough like you
can do what you want but I just think that yeah anybody defending
these lawsuits is crazy for doing so. It's damaging to all of
us.
Yes, including including Nick.
Including Willie, including everybody.
I I Do you know what? I didn't get any blowback for it. I got
blowback from Ethan's audience and I think like from Tom Foolery
but everyone was like I was like yeah, that's fine but it's just
not not on this content. I'm very open very public about it.
I was still So when still people were talking pretty
So it was fine. I think you can do that. Yes.
If you show enough deference to Nick, you can probably criticize
him sometimes.
Okay. Right?
You You do You You You can't possibly disagree that if you were
like if you're like kind of in your face if you are not very
gentle with your criticisms with Nick, you will be like nexted
instantly,
I think it depends on your relationship
to Nick. I think like again Chud was definitely in a position
where he could be. I don't think the issue was like Chud was
criticizing Nick. I think the issue was like whether this was
like led by Chud like leaning on his chat and other people cuz
it's not happening a vacuum, right? Chud has a like a large contingent
of people who want him to fight with Nick. So like from Nick's
perspective, the question is is that Chud giving an honest take
or is that Chud just being like okay, well this is what my audience
wants to do and that's the audience captured accusation.
Right? Um And also to be And also to be clear to be clear just
talking about like disagreeing disagreeing and showing deference
and everything else. Sure, there are elements to this where you
can make those arguments, but like I ended up in a pretty bloody
spat with Willie. And that soured like some relationships.
But the person who came out and defended me was Diorio.
At a time when he had no reason to.
And I don't mean just publicly. I mean privately Diorio defended
me to people.
Like Diorio defended me to Willie.
Didn't work. Didn't didn't play out in the long term.
But like he had no reason to do that. Cuz I cuz again at the
time everyone wanted me to burn Sunday and I refused to do it.
>> Okay. So I just don't I don't I'm not sure I entirely
buy this from my own experience. And I was a much less close
to Diorio than Chud was. That you couldn't talk about >> Sorry,
I That like Chud could never say anything. Otherwise he'd like
end that relationship. I I don't >> say couldn't say anything.
I was saying you have to be respectful in your
That it's like if you get to know him >> friends with some
they're like But what do you Okay, what do you mean by respectful?
Like if I I don't know. >> I mean that Chud threw Chud
threw in a throwaway line and then I believe he either followed
that up with I think must have followed that up with like a total
defense of Nicholas.
Right? I'm actually good friends with Nicholas. You guys it's
the same stream, right? Where he says Nicholas you're Yes, Nicholas
Diorio I'm talking to you. Then he does like a whole defense
of >> there But isn't there a certain element of that with
Hold on. Isn't there a certain element with all It's like again,
I think Chud handled certain things like with the Tommy stuff
badly. And I think that this is like a complete [__]
show. But I I've got the provisos in this during of like, well,
listen, I've spent years defending like this community to people.
And I've lost relationships because of my relationship to like
people like Queenman and Chud's community. So there those provisos
are still there. Am I Am I showing deference? I think I'm just
being honest to point out like if Like again, there are plenty
of people who accuse me of sweeping for Queenman. And it's like
look, if I think Queenman's wrong on something, which I have
done, by the way, particularly like look at some of the tiger
stuff, I will argue with Queenan. It's like again, I don't think
that people choosing treating Queenan like a boogeyman's kind
of
But at the same time, in this case Cuz I'm pretty sure Queenan
would love to engage with their criticism. I'm pretty sure Queenan
wouldn't just like block them on Twitter, wouldn't just like
block them wherever you do. Like Queenan would actually like
engage with the criticism, right?
>> Okay, yeah, sure. That's half of the issue, right? I
think okay. So, yeah, sure. I get that. There's definitely a
change in a move, but the way like commentary generally, not
just the commentary community, but commentary generally seems
to have shifted
pretty hard, right? I was saying before I came on here, I know
that there are going to be people in your chat who whatever I
say during this, no matter how reasonable, no matter how logical,
it's like it doesn't it won't move the goalposts because everyone's
sides a pick. In the same way that no matter what you say during
this conversation, my chat is going to side with me. So, like
these cuz like the audience overlap just doesn't exist in the
same way. There is there is much more of a tribal
break than there used to be. So, it doesn't there's not the same
value to going and having a conversation. Why put yourself in
a position where you're just going to get like for the conversation?
Like I'll do it because I like talking to you and I don't really
give a [__] what your chat thinks. But like realistically,
like what's the benefit? Like what's the gain? I'm not going
to gain any viewers of this. All I'm going to do is gain hate.
You're not going to gain any viewers on my side of it. The whole
idea is like we both have So, the reason I value this conversation
is cuz I think probably I really dislike Nicholas. I'm going
to see the faults in everything he does. And you like Nicholas,
so you're going to see the faults in either things other people
do or you're going to see some like positive silver linings in
things he does. And then I can come on and actually talk to you
and get a good understanding of like how somebody with a different
perspective sees him and the
I said this before, right? Do you want to come on so it's a bit
more balanced? Right, I'd rather have the balance
Um, I completely agree with you. But like from the perspective
of like some of this drama, like we're talking about with like
Nick and Chud and like other things, it's like well, is that
how valuable is that other side? How genuine is that other side?
Also with a friendship drama, what [__] why the [__]
would anyone debate this
It's not really giving a perspective >> Cuz we It's just
literally like the entire I Is that not the entire thing here?
We talk about [__] like this like publicly all the
time. Even though it's, you know, I I You're from art commentary.
Isn't this like 95% of the content?
Is having people on who talk about this all the time? >> what
Okay. Yeah, but that we're talk but to do that. You shouldn't
do that. It's a really bad idea. In fact, I mean and again, you
and I have had conversations about like just general like metro
life things or like the like stuff around content or like where
people say same way in lots of content creators do.
But that doesn't need to be shrunk on it or when we've disagreed
over some of the cherry stuff, not all of that needed to be public
cuz some of it's just like a concern over these things. It doesn't
need to be content.
And like I think that there are plenty of situations >> what
you're talking about that didn't get talked about publicly. I
feel like everything we talked about privately, we also talked
about on our streams once. Like Resi there.
Yeah, I think we've done I like we've done deeper stuff, but
it's like
it's not the same situation. I guess I'm trying to I'm trying
to draw an allusion. It's not the same as having like Let's say
you and I fell out over something that happened. I I don't know.
Let's say I was talking a lot of [__] about you.
Um, and you were like, "Hey, Beckett, I'm really really not happy
about the [__] you're talking about me. I thought
we were cool." I don't know. It's It's one of those where oh
[__] man. Um, sorry. I don't I didn't realize. Uh,
let's just have a quick call. We can just hash it out and maybe
I'm being a bit too harsh. Maybe I'm taking influence from another
creator or like where your position is. But, that seems to have
been offered
to Chud. Chud seems to have not wanted to have those conversations
privately, at least from the DMs.
and this is like it I don't know the the
So, you are understanding that is like >> know how difficult
it is to get a response out of Diorio. It seems like Chud was
getting responses out of Diorio on multiple platforms.
That's They They That's putting you in a tough spot though, right?
Like, imagine I gave you Imagine I gave you private information
that makes you take like a public stance that you can't really
defend because of the private information. What do you do now?
I put you in a weird position, right? >> like the New Year's
Eve stream? >> Um, possibly. I don't know what you're referencing
for the New Year's Eve stream there. No, I'm just I'm just saying
so. I mean, cuz that was the that was the issue around the New
Year's Eve stream, uh, people had private information in differing
levels of private information. They had because of the uh Pixie
Arda
There was a massive disparity in who knew what during that stream.
That's why the fight happened. Yeah. Okay. Yeah, there was a
massive disparity in who knew what during that stream and how
much information people The person who had the most information
at that time was Chud Logic. Was the fight over something to
do with that information?
It's because like it's because the the general thing is
Tom was put in a position of talking about this without the same
level of
Uh, well, okay. Not just by Chud cuz he Nick brought up in a
joke, but rather than dropping the conversation, >> And
then somebody else like actually got the conversation going.
Right? Yeah, but at the same time it's like you back out of that
conversation. I'm not saying like again that I I I earlier in
the stream that whole thing
everyone involved in it should have been way more careful if
they weren't going to talk about it publicly. But regardless,
that's the accusation around it. It's like you had more information
than us. And talked about it. It's like took a much harder stance
than
everyone else when this stuff you knew wasn't public. That's
the general accusation.
It's not just you brought up the Destiny stuff. Maybe. I mean,
I'm pretty sure Chud was just pushing back on on Tom with Tom
specifically. Wasn't it that like Molina was actually an Only
Fans girl in kind of a And so
Do you Do you think like any of the Pixie DMs helped with that?
Well, it was to do with I'd have to rewatch the stream because
it was it seemed to be to do with more than that because Chud
was like, "No, he's guilty. He's obviously guilty of more than
just this Molina stuff. I don't know why we're leaning on this
Molina stuff." And again, I'm doing this a bit from memory. I'd
have to rewatch it.
>> I I'll just I If anybody wants to correct me on this,
I believe it was Tom saying that like he didn't believe Molina
cuz Molina had come out and said none of that was consensual.
Like I didn't consent any of those pictures being released. And
then Tom said, "Well, I don't know about that. You got like an
Only Fans or sh Right? And Chud kind of jumped in there was like,
"Come on, man."
I'm Yeah, that's pretty much basically the the way it went down.
yeah, let's Okay, cuz I don't want to start misquoting things
from a stream that was like a year or year or over a year ago.
>> Yeah, this is what I remember. So Again, this is like
the Yeah, this is just like cuz I cuz that was it was a it was
a long conversation.
Um but yeah, like the the annoyance came down to people feeling
and maybe Tom, maybe others um that Tom was put in a position
where he was being
picked up over information he either didn't know and people couldn't
correct because the actual sort of proof, if you like, wasn't
made public and no one knew what to do with the DMs and that's
uh and as I said earlier, this is one of the reasons I released
them, they were a cognito hazard. Knowing about them was a problem.
I mean, what's your what's your view then on things like, you
know, if Nick's trying to keep this line open with Chud? Is that
not like a fair way to do it? He's not like cutting him off completely.
If other people don't want to do like jump on a Chud Logic stream,
is that Nick's responsibility?
Like how what's the what's the level of blame we're placing here,
I guess? >> I can only speak to like it depends on what
they thought of each other in terms of being friends, being peers,
right? Like I could say that if I knew >> very close.
So. Yeah, if I knew like my friend, like somebody who was my
friend was like kind of getting over in a way and I I was in
group chats where this guy's getting like getting called a snake,
somebody goes live, starts calling him a snake, starts invoking
my name, other people's name. I go to try to clean that up because
like despite the fact that we're having a fight,
it's like that's a that's what you do when you're friends and
you you clean it up and then you you fix that a little bit and
then you separate.
That's my personal, but I mean that's just me. I I can't say
that's like a moral requirement for most people. I don't think
you just let those people talk [__] cuz this guy
refuses to come and like kiss the ring sufficiently
to come and like apologize and do the call and have this hash
this all out in
Yeah, I mean But again, if you if you don't see each other as
peers or friends, then maybe that all makes sense. It just depends
on how they see each other, right?
I don't know, isn't there like isn't there like a separate thing
there of like Nick's being considered in the same way Chud is
that it's like we're sweeping for your friends? And it's like
getting involved, Nick's bias towards Chud is pretty publicly
known. Wait, say that again. How is his bias coming into
Because everyone knows that Nicholas DeOrio and Chud are friends.
So, him stepping in at all is like, well, you know, it this has
come as a shock to a lot of viewers. They weren't aware that
Chud and Nick had fallen out at all. Right? So, it's not like
Chud's been It's not like Nick's been openly trying
over Chudlogic or anything. No one No one had any clue until
Nick started taking shots back a couple like at the start of
the year. No, wait. No, we did have a clue from the Tommy stuff.
Not not to any significant degree because no one else guessed
this, did they? No No one else was sat there being like, well,
of course of course Chud and Nick had fallen out. Like, go back
and watch Nick's chat. Nick's chat is like, wait, what's going
on? Why Why don't we like Chud now? What What's happened? What
What's happened with Chud? Like, the whole audience is like [__]
surprised. Even now after tonight, people like, "I didn't even
realize that Chud and Nick weren't cool. I thought they were
besties."
Yeah, but >> So, like, clearly again,
it's it's not like having >> It's not like a significant
thing that people are massively aware of. I Maybe it's just like
your side is not aware of it cuz you guys don't talk about it.
I don't know. Literally every single chatter or person I know
is super aware of this.
>> Okay, but at the same time, hold on. Isn't [laughter]
if anyone's in that sort of echo chamber, wouldn't it be you
guys' side cuz you guys like hate Nick and everyone else? You
You guys are talking about this constantly.
He's okay. >> So, so wait. Hold on. Hold on. You didn't
even disagree with the point in a
about like Nick probably wanted that to You didn't even disagree
with that.
Okay, I'm saying I don't know. Maybe he did. Maybe he disagreed
over the Willy stuff and was pissed off about it. Who [__]
knows? But, my point is Chud's
responsibility then if they're friends? So, if you're saying
that Nick had a responsibility to come out
through all this like Ethan Hasan Destiny stuff when Nick's getting
a load of [__] from everybody in Queerman and his
own chat and community. Surely then Chud should be the one coming
out and saying, "No, Nick's coverage is is fine and you're all
like you need to chill and I was going to >> is he's letting
Nick know in private, "I don't think your coverage is fine."
And he's literally saying, "My problem here is that I don't want
to come out and say that cuz it's going to feed the other
So, what do I do? I feel really bad. I mean, ultimately that's
I guess from the position of like where Chud was at.
I don't know. I like either come out or shut up, really. It's
sort of like if I disagree with somebody I'm friendly with in
the same way when I disagree with Nick, I'm in an even worse
position. I just I just came out and said I mean, I mean, yeah.
To an extent, sure. But it's it's kind of ended up as this drip
feed.
Yeah, he got the worst of all worlds, right? Like he held off
criticizing the guy, so it's pretty obvious that he was sweeping
for Nick back then. And he also gets like over now and the friendship
ends. So, all the sweeping was like for nothing.
Got kind of the worst of every world >> part of the problem
is it's like how much does it matter? How much does this Ethan,
Hasan, Destiny [__] matter to
Like or Nick's coverage matter to Chud?
Because like I don't I don't think Chud actually really cares
if like one of his friends is doing coverage and is like, "I
disagree with that." And why would
Why the [__] would it matter? If you do coverage
of something
and I disagree with you and I'm like it's not like something
I'm covering. Like right now within the ACC there are people
who are doing coverage of like a couple of like a couple of things
happened and I was like, "Ah, okay. I think that's a bit in that
direction." But it's not really that important. So, whatever.
I'm not covering it, so I don't need to talk about it.
have at it.
I don't think it's like a surface level like I think we could
agree to disagree thing here, right? He's basically saying you're
like sweeping. Probably a lot of financial reasons to sweep.
It's probably not stuff that are like is super comfortable, right?
I would imagine those would be your criticisms. Like it's not
it's not super easy to just, yeah, throw those I don't I think
he should have, but it's pretty clear he's like talking to Nick
about it and he's like not sure where to go with it. At least
it seemed pretty clear to me. I mean And then I don't know why
they get to the point where they're like talking down to him
before they ever make the call.
Well, I know that it was I think that was but at the same time
it's like
I don't know what the what's the good way to put that?
I don't know why it matters.
And it seems the only reason it would matter is because of audience
pressure,
Would you agree with that? Cuz Chud's under audience pressure
to talk about it.
I think Hold on. It's it's literally that he tangibly disagrees.
If he doesn't tangibly disagree with Nick on anything, I don't
think that he succumbs to audience pressure. Because when he
didn't disagree with Nick on stuff, his audience still hated
Nick. His audience has hated Nick for like a year now. Like since
before the Destiny stuff leaked, they've hated Nick. They they
constantly talk to him anytime he's in that chat. Yeah, they
despise this guy. Yeah, but they don't Hold on. But they should
they should talk to any content creator. Spicy chat oncs have
hated [clears throat] this guy forever, okay? For like >> Okay.
Okay, yeah. over a year now. But like but people get [__]
talked in Chud's chat
all the time. And I suppose this is one of the reasons I'd point
to the fact that I said I thought something like this was going
to happen years ago. Because the same [__] happened
with Twitch politics.
Like if you go back and listen to the Go go back and listen to
the old Ryze home stream where he's talking to Chud about spicy
chat. It's your harboring this community. And it's like And again,
I've said I said during this stream, I don't think you should
care what other people's audiences think of you. I think that's
ridiculous. I think it's ri- Mhm. But content creators do. This
shouldn't come as a surprise to Chud that this has been the outcome
because this has been the outcome for for relationships with
other content creators multiple times
This isn't new. Uh sure. It's exactly >> exactly what's
happened before, right?
Well, he's he's You're saying he's You're describing what happens
when narcissists get criticized, by the way. You know that, right?
Like you're you're literally like obviously a ton of streamers,
that's the reason they do it is they >> pretending Are
we pretending Yeah, are we pretending that streamers and YouTubers
aren't like like isn't this tailored to narcissists?
>> It is, but I'm saying that like that's what's going
on there. Is it not something you should be like, "Oh, that's
that's fine." And you It's You could say you should expect that.
>> but on the same but on the same level but on the same
level at some But on the same but on the same level at some degree,
it's like, "Okay, well, you know that's going to be the outcome."
And that's why when you're dealing with friends or people you're
close with, you are more careful with those relationships cuz
you know it's going to be a problem. You can say that's part
Well, I think that's why Isn't that literally why he defended
Nicholas like every single time his chat was going in on that
guy for months and months? I I again, I don't watch enough Chud
to say that like it it seems to me that it would like lots of
little shots and wasn't the criticism here that like Wait, where
are Where are those lots of little shots? I actually I that I
asked that. I was like, "Are there like a whole bunch of things
he's not referring to?" Where are the other little shots? Yeah,
I mean Uh so, it's things like um DiOrio gets brought up in chat
and Chud will take a little shot over a little uh something that
Nick said on Twitter or there's a tweet somewhere. And like the
same way that like Chud does with a lot of people. I don't think
this is like an issue. It's just I I I think there is an element
here where there's maybe a British element to this show where
it's like, you know, you're friendly with somebody, so you take
those little shots. But I'd have to go through and see a lot
of them. Um but yeah, it seemed like this was a pretty constant
thing. And it felt like to people like
uh from what I've heard that
once you're the content,
regardless of your relationship with Chud, you're going to get
the same sort of you're going to get talked about in exactly
the same way
as like anyone who's getting Chud is aggressive
and he like
and that's not going to play well to everybody and I think that's
one of the reasons that his like
relationship started to break down. I mean cuz the other accusation
was that Chud brought up the Bowblax stuff on the like the dress
wearing thing on the New Year's stream which everyone had agreed
to keep quiet. And like again
I've said this publicly, I truly believe Chud just didn't know
whether that was public or not. I don't think he was trying to
leak anything to cause drama.
but yeah, I think also some of it's culture stuff where it's
like is he really one of us?
Which is you know, happens in a lot of communities. But to like
return to like the I guess the core point. It's like yes, you
know that you're dealing with people where
if you say something, especially about a friend, especially about
someone you have a good relationship with, that's going to be
clipped, it's going to be used against them, so you're careful
about it.
You have to be.
If I if I said something about Queenman people are going to clip
that and then send it to Queenman or like post it in whatever
his farm chat is. If I say something about Aiden or I say something
about anybody. We know how people are going to react. Ending
the friendship when it's literally just like a like a meme.
Are you are you sincerely worried about that like ending a friendship?
Um I think that there would be certain situations
where like I would be very careful about what I said with certain
things, yeah.
Like with with certain people and certain dramas depending on
what's going on with them.
Yeah, I'd be aware of oh that's probably going to I know this
person that's going to piss them off and they're dealing with
all this other [__] cuz I got personal relationships.
I might be a bit more careful. Just out of just because they're
my friend.
Okay. So there's like nothing to do with drama or something.
It's just like I Yeah, if this person's getting a load of I'm
probably not going to poke at them
or feed the fire in any way cuz they're dealing with other stuff.
wouldn't it wouldn't it depend on like wouldn't it literally
just depend on how justifiable that criticism is? Like I don't
know I can't come up with a perfect metaphor off the top of my
head, but it's like you are basically like Chud clearly made
he made it very clear he felt like he was sweeping for Nick in
those DMs. Do you disagree with that? I'd have to reread the
DMs. I think that I think it's clear that Chud feels like he's
caught between his relationship with Nick and his audience, yeah.
It's not just it's not the audience. He's not scared of his audience.
He calls Stylo like a house and all the time. He's not scared
of Stylo. We know he's not scared of Stylo, right?
I'm not saying >> like a [__] against Nick
hater. And I didn't say I didn't say I didn't say scared. I never
used the word scared. Other people have used the word scared.
I didn't use the word scared. >> When you say when you
say caught between his relationship with the Nick and his audience,
that implies that he's worried about losing one of the two.
And it's like he's not worried about those people turning on
him in some way the way Nick implied.
What he's worried about is literally being guilty of sweeping
when they So with that when they call him a sweeper this time,
it's not just a meme, it's not just a joke, it's not just funny.
It's like literally true.
That's what he's concerned about. Do you do you really disagree
with that depending on your I mean you could watch Maybe you
could watch like my reading of the DMs. >> So part of the
So part of the So part of the problem here is Uh actually, hold
on.
Give me give me a sec. So.
Do you want to try to go through the DMs? Could we get Does anybody
have like a an album of the DMs? I mean I'm talking about the
some of the Twitter DMs and stuff.
Okay. So, I don't think that's the case.
And I don't think it's just I'm scared of being called a sweeper
because I actually am.
I I'm not reading the DMs in that
Okay. So,
but I think we're just going to have to sort of agree to disagree
here.
Yeah, sure. >> So, does that Yeah. Yeah, I think it's one
of those where
I don't know what was happening directly in Chud's mind, but
>> Do you Do you think Chud is truly terrified of Perry,
the
the Maltese menace?
I think Chud is very I think Chud is very aware
Let's go ahead and put this. I think Chud's priority
is making content and making money in the same way many content
creators are, and he is aware of his audience perceptions and
doesn't want to just like he memes about this, but the ice stuff
and the Charlie Kirk take around Asmongold, like that annoyed
him. Like it obviously annoyed him when he lost audience over
that. And he's got sections of his audience that like do strongly
disagree and will have like takes that would like obvious No
one is trying to burn section of their audience en masse except
for maybe me when I get pissed off. And again, I can afford to
do that cuz I don't take a paycheck, but this is his livelihood.
>> You've got like a median IQ of like 85 in this chat.
It's It's very dragging. Oh my [__] god. Listen,
why the [__] are you reading my chat? Why the [__]
are you reading my chat? God damn. Uh I enjoy it. I I You could
You could pull any of these people in. I would love that. It
would be very funny.
>> Okay, buddy.
So, anyway,
anyway, we're just going to have to agree to disagree.
>> Um sure. On that one, yeah, I I I guess if if that's
the case.
I think that I think that ultimately like this blow up was predictable.
But at the same time, like it it they should have resolved it
months ago. Both of them should have done. And they seem to have
had opportunities and neither of them took it.
I And also, there is another thing. >> I think I think
totally dodging any of this TommyC stuff was like tragic from
Nicholas to pretend that that wasn't a thing. To pretend that
Chud should have just ignored it. That's like the take I'm disagreeing
with you overall is the idea that Chud should take that credibility
attack that's that's using Nick's name to give lend weight to
it and he should not respond to it. That to me is insane.
Yeah, I think it's just really obvious from my perspective perspective
what Tommy was trying to do. And that's why Chud should have
ignored it. Cuz again, like you didn't need to fight >> it's
signals to every content creator that Chud is actually guilty
there of something if he doesn't respond to this guy saying,
"Hey, you know I talk You know I'm in group chats with all these
Every every creator in commentary knows that, right? You know
I'm in group chats with all these guys and he says, "These guys
all hate you. You're a snake."
And Chud literally can't respond. Chud It was bad for Chud to
respond to that.
It was Okay, well, Chud needed to >> looks really bad to
me.
All Chud needed to say was, "Well, people can come and talk to
me. I'm right here. I wasn't aware of this, but I don't care
beyond that." That's all Chud needed to say. He didn't do He
didn't need to do a back and forth. He didn't need to do reactions.
That's what looked bad.
And again, you can again, it's fine. It's fine. It's fine. Tommy's
saying if you do talk to him, if you go and talk to him, you're
going to get [__] over.
But then Okay, but then going and talking to him is attacking
his ability to have those conversations.
But then Okay, then
even if that's the case, the way you agree with that, right?
I'll meet
No, I don't think it because he's talking to 100 people. It's
irrelevant. He's got no audience overlap with him. It's like
Chud like again, by Chud responding in a hyper aggressive way
to Tommy. If Chud had gone live and just
got been like, "I don't understand why Tommy's doing this. This
is really weird. Like I'm happy to talk to him. Clearly some
wires have got crossed. If I've crossed some lines, maybe we
can just talk about it and have like a really peaceful conversation.
I'm not going to do go at Tommy." In fact, I know this to kind
of be the case because Tommy C did an even more insane vitriolic
attack on me when the Destiny stuff happened. Like Tommy C directly
called for me to be burned from the commentary community. He's
like, "Nobody should talk to Becca. Becca this guy needs to die."
Like hyper aggressive. I got told about this. I just went, "Yeah,
like Tommy's Tommy said this publicly.
That's fine. >> say that like Turkey Tom hates Becca? Nicholas
DeOrio hates Becca? >> Yeah, he said that multiple people
were talking behind the the behind the >> name? Who I know
in commentary? I can't remember. I'd have to go back and check.
I I I have to go back and check. But again, this was like a pretty
brutal attack. And all I did was say, "Listen, I'm not offended
or anything else." And then I did like one of my people who's
close with Tommy DM'd me this and I was like, "Look, I'm happy
to talk to Tommy." Had a quick chat with Tommy and he was like,
"Okay, cool." And he just went and apologized the next
And like and again, he was directly calling me for me to be burned
by the content creators from the [__]
We We all understand Tommy was not going to take an apology for
this, right? He didn't want an apology. It's not even remotely
the same thing. I I don't know. I'm just I'm just giving you
my experience here. Like and again, this is Sorry. Like I might
have misspoke there. I I'm saying he wouldn't have given an apology
on this. He was He was literally just speaking. I don't think
anybody really denies that he was just speaking the truth there.
All of the creators he's referencing were in his chat for these
streams. Okay, sure. I mean, isn't that even more of a reason
to try and like de-escalate this and like deal with it privately?
Rather than booting up a stream and trying to
like I don't I don't lean into it. I I just don't I don't see
how Chud wins by
What is it What did Chud gain by responding to Okay, so here's
the question. You say Chud was right to respond. How's that turned
out for him?
Well, hold on. But you agree with me that the attack on credibility
is important an attack on your credibility is important. They're
invoking a bigger creator who you're like kind of friends with
to do that and those creators are co-signing it by being present.
Then that would be a big thing. What do you But we're But we're
looping in the Like substantive allegations against you just
not responding them is very rarely the play. I don't understand
how you can possibly say that's the play.
So again, responding to it the way Chud did was the wrong way
to respond to it. We're in the aftermath of it. Right? There
were better ways to handle this than the way Chud did. I'm not
saying do like nothing at all. It's like just But publicly, like
the next day, ignore it. Ignore it. I don't I don't understand
how this is like >> So handle it all in private. Like people
talk [__] about you in public and handle it all in
private in a way that benefits Give it a couple of [__]
you [__] about you. >> be like and just be
like look, you can just be like it doesn't really matter to me.
It's whatever. People can come and talk to me. But like yes,
a huge vitriol extreme was the wrong way to handle it. I mean
again, you can see the aftermath, right? This like hit Chud doing
those like streams on Tommy has not hit Tommy particularly hard.
It's like Tommy's
And at the same time, talk then other people have used that in
Chud's response to further damage Chud. So I don't understand
how Chud responding in the way that he did can put Well, Tommy's
done that. Willy's done that. Like I'm sure other people behind
the scenes maybe can do that. They just like If Tommy couldn't
do the first time, certainly he couldn't do it in a follow-up,
could he?
What do you mean?
Uh Tommy couldn't hurt him. Chud could have just ignored. Surely
Tommy is irrelevant regardless of what he does, right? Isn't
that the argument you're
Yeah, but you validate Tommy by responding to him publicly in
this way.
He was validated by other people. >> He was validated by
people before Chud
I don't think you could really deny that. Those people participating
validated him. I think it becomes the wider question of like
whether cuz people are now doing the thing where it's like, "Well,
Tommy was right
Right? You provide that ammunition.
I just I just think the obvious thing to do in these situations
is take a breath
and not click the live and and be pushed into talking about it
right away.
You you're like it it it seems like handle with care is just
sensible advice. I don't I don't know why this is contentious.
Yeah. >> could be sensible advice. I'm just saying that
like having any criticism for Chud's handling that situation
that is within an order of magnitude of your criticism for every
other creator involved in that situation is silly to me. Like
obviously every other creator involved there is far more guilty.
>> is to do with the And so saying that I think Chud has
handled this wrong >> Okay, okay, but you're saying but
you're saying wrong. But you're saying but you're saying wrong.
I'm talking about strategy. I'm not talking about ethics or what
the right thing to do is like being a nice person. I'm talking
about strategy in dealing with something. If you just want to
say strategically Chud could have handled that better um in a
less public like more obscured way, like possibly he could have
gone and kissed the ring behind the scenes and just made this
all go away and Tommy comes out and says, "Oh, actually I was
just drunk again, guys. Haha." Yeah, probably.
Sure. So that's but that is my core
>> existence, right? Okay, sure. Sure.
But again, like this is this is people's careers and like we
are down to like how well you can network and talk to people.
That's fairly important for a streamer like Chud. So yeah, you're
like again
>> Bro, I could have just stayed in corporate I could have
just stayed in corporate tech, okay? If I wanted to constantly
kiss the ring. [__] Unfortunately, life is lots of
ring
Look, I'm just I'm just I'm just saying I'm just saying if you
want like a revised statement that's less ranty, yes, the way
Chud dealt with the Tommy stuff strategically was bad. Okay?
I'm not talking about the ethics. I'm not talking about how Chud
was treated. I'm just saying
strategically
was a dumb move.
Okay. Okay? And I said it was at the time. You can go back and
watch the coverage cuz people like you're sitting on the fence.
I was like no, this is on both sides. Chud shouldn't be respon
I think I say that in my when I'm talking about it. Chud shouldn't
have responded to her. I said this months ago. >> Yeah,
no, it's [__] you say it's between Tommy and Chud,
but there are other creators at play >> Tommy's I think
I think Tommy's I think
Okay, I mean I like is this just like a mass like who does Bakko
dislike within commentary? I don't think there are many secrets
with those, right?
Well, yeah, I mean like again I don't think there's many secrets
that I've like when other people have done things I've called
it within commentary. Did this with Willy with the doxing stuff
and um Oh, sure. I'm saying that >> around like Dickers
and everything else,
What about Dickers?
When Dickers uh tweeted out like retweeted the Destiny post and
Willy was like this guy doxxed doxxed me.
I was like that's a
Oh. Yeah, I mean Willy Willy didn't even say I don't even think
he called out Dickers. I think he called out me for retweeting
Dickers to be fair. Possibly, yeah. I don't know. Okay. I I I'm
sorry. I say I think that is definitely what he did. He called
out me for retweeting Dickers.
Yeah, it was right. Um anyway, okay. >> again, anytime
it seems like anytime you're willing to name the that is never
Nicholas.
>> Which is I think just speaks to like a wider if you
if you want to kneel before Nicholas, you he will get his cloud.
But you always have to kneel before
And I just think I think that's like a little goofy. And it's
not on the surface. It's not people don't just generally like
say that's the way it is. But it is very obvious that that's
the way it is. I just I think it's kind of hold on hold on hold
on a second cuz like again
when it comes to when it comes to Nick, it depends on the situation.
And like what the [__] am I meant to
I don't know.
What the [__] would you have me say about Nicholas
that I like I don't know. I I feel like I treat
people pretty
similar. I I I feel like with Chud I've been pretty defensive
of Chud. I'm defensive of like Queman when >> was He's
in those videos. >> was vulgar. He didn't say anything
Well, Chud was vulgar. He didn't say anything wrong. May 29th,
Chud said nothing wrong. He was vulgar, but he said nothing wrong.
Wait, May 29th, what do you mean? What would say >> That
is the >> Which which clip?
It's really dry out here unless you want to suck Ethan Klein's
for shackles or whatever the [__] he said it. The
shackles thing I think is later, right? Yes, I'm talking to you
Nicholas DeOrio. He was vulgar, but he was correct.
Yeah, sure.
Have I Have I Hold on. Haven't I Have I not said this? Yeah,
have I not said this? I think I've I think I've said this pretty
publicly over the last >> in different words. You said
it in different words.
Okay, sure. >> You know what I mean? You You say it like
very generally.
I don't even mind that. I think I don't even mind that because
I think you are that way temperamentally. Like this is just I'll
sweep for you a little bit. I I think you're that way temperamentally
with more than just Nicholas. I think you are that way with people
you're friends with. You're like you'll say this is the principle
I I find. And if somebody really presses you, eventually they'll
say, "Yeah, this person it applies to them, too." But I think
that's generally how you are. You That's just You're not going
to go directly at people that way unless they're like doing videos,
right?
>> Yeah, look at my videos. Look at the KP coverage. Even
at the end of the KP like the first eight-spot video, I'm like,
"I don't think KP's malicious. I think she's just dumb." And
I got criticized for doing that. Cuz I tend to be balanced with
everybody. Um but when it comes to like if you want like the
Oh, yeah, this coverage of Ethan, Hasan, Destiny has been like
a milk like everyone's milked this and it's like been the only
content in the last year was boring because of the >> No,
yeah. I said the No, sorry. It was It was a lighter criticism
than that. It was to a fault. You've You've taken the side of
Ethan Klein to a fault. >> fault if you just want to What?
For Nicholas Oh, yeah, sure. Sure. I said this with the Which
you said with the lawsuits already. Yeah, yeah. >> Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah, just Sorry. I'm just I just re-treading my own words.
Yeah. Yeah. That was obviously aimed at everyone who was covering
it. Whether it was Willy, Nick, anyone. I was like, "No, the
court case stuff should have been treated far more harshly."
And like recognized as a potentially a floodgates opening. Yeah,
I've said that publicly. It's fine. I also And once again, didn't
get blocked.
Also, I I did notice right at the you did throw some Hasan is
bads in there. Could we get Did you give a little credit to the
people who were on that train early? Okay?
You don't have to. What? The um I see I see a bunch of people
swapping sides on that now. When I got get I was getting called
a Hasan dick sucker for saying this has gone too far. Okay? >> once
again, once again, I know your audience don't watch me, uh but
I have said this before. I've said it's this side cut tribal
[__] where it's like we have to we have to side with
people who are against Hasan even if they are total pieces of
[__] is [__] ridiculous. I'm saying this
all through last year. Um I got accused of being a Hasan fan
at one point. But the fact that I hate all of them.
I said nice things about Denims at one
I mean, [__] all these people, that's my view. Right?
Hasan, Destiny, Vosh, they're all in the same category to me.
>> Well, no, no, no. >> I've literally argued with
Kweeman about this publicly. Well, they do for me. >> I've
argued about this publicly, yeah, [__] all of them.
What is What is Sorry, sure. What has Hasan done that's like
worse >> no, no, where Where Destiny is Where No, no, where
Destiny is now it's worth Sure, sure. But like they've all been
in the same category as me for me for years. Um but sure, yeah.
>> I Sure, in terms of like purely their political, not
their personal things, just their political, I would say yeah,
sure. I could put them in the same >> Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
Uh like for their personal stuff, yeah, Destiny's obviously worse.
Yeah, this I Sorry, I was just like very >> I was just
saying Destiny's worse and like and Big Bungey is and Big Bungey
is based for not being sus.
Um recently uh in one of his streams. Yes, there is a massive
thing here where it's just like oh, we have to make sure that
we're hating Hasan and all this um at the detriment of anything
else.
I love I love the Hasan and Denims, you
Nazi edits, the Hitlerian Denims and
Don't miss the train on Hitlerian Emiru,
Aryan Emiru, number one upcoming meme. Like I'm I'm I'm I'm you
know, I'm generally like I think all the Twitch aristocracy are
freaks, but anyway. Sure. I think there's probably something
that breaks internally in your brain if you get millions of dollars
by the time you're 22 or something.
You probably just don't ever get to be a good human at that point.
>> Asmongold is? Can we talk how cut Asmongold is?
On not criticizing Teekatonn Nux and these other people or what?
On the
Asmongold was defending food shops recently. Somebody who he's
like
I like aware and has had drama with. It was bizarre.
Unless there's more to that clip, unless there there's more to
that clip, I do think he was basically just going, "Why is Hasan
calling everyone a cuz Hasan happens to have had, you know, he's
got the aura, so all of his enemies seem to be just seem to,
you know, get caught talking to kids, looking at drawn pictures
of kids. It just seems to keep happening over and over again.
And so, Hasan keeps calling these people out, Teckton, Asmongold.
Well, Teckton was just a No, Teckton Yeah, Teckton's a kid, too.
Damn. I forgot about that for a second.
anime kids, little different, maybe, or maybe not, depending
on your thoughts.
>> Reviews Okay, so So, Asmongold's watching Hasan call
all those people and Asmongold just goes, "Dude, why is everybody
getting Hasan a
I think that was the quote-unquote defensive food shops.
In that same clip, he goes, "Yeah, this covers me, too." Cuz
he did like a video as well. Oh, did he actually?
>> Okay. Yeah, it's like I don't know if it's actually
a defensive food shops, to be honest with >> be missing
things. Yeah, I could be missing things. That's fine. I'm just
I just did. I crushed out over seeing the like, dude. I can't
believe he called me a bad father to trans women for food shops.
Just annoyed me. >> Oh, yeah, it was very goofy.
>> That's And Andrew Wilson jumping on the sucking train,
as well, dude.
Yeah, I I assume Andrew didn't really think that. Did you see
Andrew and Erudite are debating tonight? [laughter]
Are they actually? >> Yeah. 8-hour whatever debate. Let's
see if that's on right now. Oh, Whatever.
Okay, well, look, I'm going to go back to watching this next
stuff. All over minds.
We're Um >> and 1/2 hours into this debate, guys. Andrew's
hair is totally Okay, you got to go back to the video, okay?
Thank you for talking to me. >> Yeah, yeah. Okay. No worries.
>> We'll see you later. Bye.